moore alors les candidats de droite
comme de gauche on l'a vu sont tous ou
presque dans les starting blocks unité
affichée à droite derrière la candidate
désignée valérie pécresse qui affirme
que la droite est de retour alors est-ce
le car la droite est elle vraiment de
retour comme l'affirment sa
représentante c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage ce soir
est avec nous pour en parler philippe
bouyer sénateurs à l'ère des deux-sèvres
porte parole de valérie pécresse bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous philippe pouillé
à vos côtés alain joyandet sénateurs et
l'air de haute-saône soutien d'eric
ciotti ancien secrétaire d'état en
charge de la coopération et la
francophonie merci d'être avec nous
également bonsoir
alexis poulain qui nous accompagnent
éditorialistes d'ayrté france des dix
arbitres mais y'a rien à arbitrer à mon
cher alexis puisque cette journée a été
placée sous le signe d'une unité
parfaite on va on va en parler
maintenant d'ailleurs maintenant c'est
le temps de l'unité c'est ce que nous a
dit aujourd'hui valérie pécresse que je
vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés
alors ce que je suis venu vous dire ici
pour rassurer tous ceux qui pourraient
s'inquiéter c'est que eric aura une
place très singulière dans ma campagne
parce qu'il a une voix très singulière à
faire entendre pour le pays
alors philippe mouillé on se demande un
petit peu ce que c'est cette expression
une place singulière parce qu'ils aient
une voix singulière qu'est vous le dire
valérie pécresse parce qu'on aurait pu
parler de place centrale non elle a
parlé de singulier c'est moi je crois
que c'est le thème qui est idyllique
globalement l'idée c'est de dire que
dans ses copains littoral et elle ce qui
a forcément à travers son projet et sa
personnalité un rôle essentiel dans la
campagne électorale alors on aurait pu
dire plan central là l'idée c'est
vraiment de mobiliser tous les acteurs
mais la fois à travers son projet et
surtout sa façon d'être son
positionnement alors dû à travers
résultat aujourd'hui de la primaire eh
bien il a un rôle essentiel et la
victoire se fera avec lui ça vous
convient cette expression une place
singulière parce qu'il a une voix
singulière vous êtes en phase avec ces
mots de valérie pécresse je crois
surtout que le message c'est celui de
l'unité certes mais c'est aussi de
me faire passer
une idée à la suite de cette primaire
l'idée selon laquelle le rassemblement
peut-être selon valérie pécresse il
faudra qu'on en sache un peu plus mais
en tout cas selon eric ciotti ce
rassemblement doit se faire à droite et
je pense que c'est ça la question qui
est posée c'est où est-ce qu'on se
rassemble comment est-ce qu'on se
rassemble pour gagner cette élection 40%
pour eric ciotti tout seuls
60% pour valérie pécresse qui fait très
belle victoire
il y à une question qui se pose de
stratégie politique pour la campagne
électorale je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
réponse en tout cas j'ai compris comme
ça parce que c'est un peu subliminal
mais la réponse est celle là il faut que
ce rassemblement se fasse un peu plus à
droite qu'au centre pour gagner cette
élection alexis poulain on va évidemment
continuer à analyser parce que elle est
là la clé de l'enjeu certainement est-ce
qu'on va par la droite par le centre
c'est l'éternel débat entre ces deux
personnalités il n'empêche
eric ciotti 39% des voix qui devient
véritablement a father de roi ou de
reine en l'occurrence oui plus que ça je
crois il montre l'évolution des
républicains depuis la présidence de
laurent wauquiez de toute façon est
clairement
aujourd'hui valérie pécresse ne peut pas
faire sans lui alors cette place à part
reste à déterminer mais elle est
extrêmement important 40% seul c'est
plus que n'importe quel motion qu'on a
pu voir dans les partis de gauche on est
là sur vraiment un débat idéologique sur
ce que va être le batave le programme
des républicains vont être les idées qu
est-ce qui va être débattu et le poids
parce qu'aujourd'hui effectivement il ya
une attente de la part des militants et
puis il ya un pays qui est la france
derrière et puis il ya des nouveaux
arrivants comme eric zemmour qui vont
capitaliser aussi sur lutte libre qu'il
a écrit depuis des années mais
clairement les républicains aujourd'hui
sur un tournant important et valérie
pécresse va devoir de toute façon se
démarquer stratégiquement clairement
d'emmanuel matheron parce que il y à des
mesures de macron qui sont clairement
fait pour empêcher embêter le camp
républicain donc elle pourra compter sur
l'ex yotive pour justement avoir cette
belle vidéo logique très différente du
maquereau nisme et de la maison commune
qui est ce nouveau centre qui est
construit par edouard philippe françois
bayrou et les autres philippe maillet
vous êtes d'accord vous avec justement
ce diagnostic des ricciotti la victoire
se fera à la droite parce qu'on sent que
valérie pécresse quand même
voilà dix ans ce week-end ne veut pas
dénaturer son programme on se souvient
thème d'une malaise etc récents on en
parle peu mais enfin en 2017 et a claqué
la porte dlr parce qu'elle trouvait que
la ligne de vaud qui était beaucoup trop
doit droitière ce qu'on peut faire
confiance quand on est un proche d'eric
ciotti pour être représenté dans le
programme de valérie pécresse clairement
je crois qu'il est d'abord il ya un
message qui est très clair c'est qu'on
sait que pour gagner il faut être unis
et on voit bien que par rapport à 2010
est la france se droitise vomir à
prévert à la fois les les expressions
politiques et la rue voilà donc la ligne
politique elle est forcément rassemblés
sur un positionnement qui celui qu'a été
donné par là primaires donc la pollution
de droite là dessus il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté et le message qui a été
portée aujourd'hui les aussi notre
seigneur a été pour moi laissez
l'expression avant tout d'une place à
part et donc ces packs voilà et à
travers notamment des jours qui viennent
et la finalité des programmes on va
pouvoir travailler justement sur ces
lignes politiques et voulaient être
humain dit on a besoin clairement
aujourd'hui de parler notre électorat
qui revendiquent des idées claires de
droite et en même temps on a besoin de
se démarquer par rapport au
positionnement et bien des nouvelles
macro avec 102 mesures voilà donc
là-dessus il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté le
tout c'est que malgré tout ça il faut
aussi rassembler le plus large possible
donc c'est la fois avoir un
positionnement clairement à droite et en
même temps est bien certain nombre de
propositions qui élargissent encore la
base qui sera nécessaire parce que c'est
50 % plus nous alain joyandet elle est
où la limite entre rassembler et
épouse est vraiment une ligne de droite
et de droite forte peut-être un élément
technique politique pour illustrer ma
réponse lasorda j'ai sorti aujourd'hui
sondage ifop si je peux me permettre de
le citer ou d'un seul coup valérie
pécresse passe à 17% d'intentions de
vote dans les sondages déjà ça veut dire
que la primaire des républicains comme
nous l'espérions fait que son champion
bénéficie d'un effet de levier après le
résultat ça c'est une première chose
dans ce sondage il y à valérie pécresse
et n'y a pas de de deux personnalités
centristes qui soit mesuré donc lé sol
pour la droite et le centre et l'est à
17% à égalité avec marine le pen devant
monsieur zemmour et au deuxième tour
dans la marge d'erreur avec emmanuel
macron ce qui veut dire c'est un grand
espoir pour les républicains mais pour
répondre à la question rien emmanuel
macron si je peux me permettre au centre
quand même bien sûr c'est pour ça que je
dis que elle est mesurée au deuxième
tour avec emmanuel macron dans la marge
d'erreur on est à 52 48 et au premier
tour elle est à égalité avec madame le
pen donc prête à se qualifier pour le
deuxième tour et par rapport à ce que je
disais au début le fait qu'elle soit
seule candidate mesuré pour la droite et
le centre les points qui lui manquent
arithmétiquement en tout cas si
j'analyse ce sondage comme cela les
points qui lui manquent il faut qu'elles
les prennent où il faut qu'elles les
prennent à droite il faut qu'elles les
prix il faut qu'il y ait des électeurs
qui nous ont quittés par déception qui
sont partis chez madame le pen ou qui
sont séduits par monsieur zemmour il
faut qu on en récupère une partie pour
faire en sorte qu'on a on soit qualifié
ou au premier tour fade après le premier
tour pour le deuxième tour je rappelle
je vais lui c'est un peu une évidence
mais enfin rappelons le pour gagner le
deuxième tour il faut se qualifier c'est
à dire qu'il faut au moins deuxième lors
du premier tour d'où cette analyse mais
qui n'est pas du tout en contradiction
avec ce que vient de dire mon ami fait
dépouiller mais c'est un vrai débat
c'est de vous poser vraiment la bonne
question c'est où est ce qu'on met le
curseur et où est-ce qu'on fait le
rassemblement moi j'apporte cette
réponse peut-être que j'ai vu le sourire
quand même aujourd'hui
d'eric ciotti et valérie pécresse
j'imagine qu'ils un certain nombre de
choses qui se sont dites qui qui
permettent d'avoir ce sourire et donc
d'être d'accord sur la ligne quant à la
place d'eric ciotti dans la campagne
électorale je pense qu'on sera bientôt
alexis pour l'un j'en reviens sur ce que
je disais une valérie pécresse qu'on
présente souvent comme centriste même un
potentiellement un maquereau compatibles
on l'a répété tant de fois aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous en tant qu'analyste
politique vous la sentez prête cette
candidate républicaine
aller vers la droite d'eric ciotti
et comment placer le curseur pour elle
oui on l'a vu déjà lors des débats de la
primaire pour le congrès elle a déjà
déplacé le curseur après il ya un
problème bien sûr de débilité celle qui
a quitté le parti parce que pour elle le
rend wauquiez était de trop à droite ça
pose un problème maintenant de revenir
et d'incarner cette ligne de droite qui
est hégémonique donc il va falloir
qu'elle incarne c'est à laquelle
qu'elles prennent en crédibilité quel
travail du coup avec eric ciotti
évidemment donc on a là peut-être à
faire à un exécutif bicéphale au sein du
parti une campagne qui va se jouer à
deux et pas seulement avec valérie
pécresse il va pouvoir jouer sur toutes
les nuances de républicanisme c'est
l'idée sans doute la façon dont ça va
s'organiser pour elle il ya tout un
chemin à faire parce que les électeurs
préféreront toujours l'original à la
copie et je vois mal des électeurs
séduits par eric zemmour choisir et une
fille née de voter valérie pécresse à la
fin où les électeurs aujourd'hui
supporters des modèles macron qui irait
voir madame pécresse à la suite donc
c'est un chantier herculéen il ya
beaucoup de travail pour convaincre mais
pour ça il faut un travail d'équipé et
je pense qu'eric ciotti est une pièce
majeure dans notre travail de reconquête
de la droite de la droite en tout cas la
question de savoir si la droite est de
retour on va on va se tourner vers ses
premiers messages télégramme pécresse
égale juppé gaz sarkozy égale chirac la
pseudo droite kobe à la gauche pour ceux
qui n'auraient pas encore compris le
seul absolue droite en france est une
idéologie centriste européaniste comme
macron d'ailleurs quant à paul il dit la
droite quelle droite celle de pécresse
et celle de chirac ou sarkozy soumise à
la gauche pourquoi car ils sont d'accord
pour dire une chose le danger c'est
l'extrême droite cqfd ils font campagne
l extrême droite et gouverne au centre
je ne leur ferai plus jamais confiance
ça c'est vrai que philippe moullier il
faut l'entendre ce côté voilà c'est un
peu tiède c'est un peu ou un peu
illisible vous réfutez aujourd'hui ces
critiques oui tout est fait je crois que
on est dans une autre campagne
électorale on est aujourd'hui face à une
situation où la france évoluer ne
navigue pas favorablement et que les
réponses qui sont attendus sont des
réponses qui doivent être fermes et à la
fois humaniste c'est vraiment le pilier
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a bien à
travers la campagne des primaires moi
j'ai tourné tout d'ailleurs
entendre on l'évoqué le fait du départ
de valérie pécresse c'est plus le sujet
on a le résultat aujourd'hui elle était
placée en tête et on voit que la ligne
parce que parce que la relation avec les
républicains a changé c'est plutôt une
brume attaques internes et or bien
qu'aujourd'hui à la fois les dés
positionne en tête et que la ligne porté
par ciotti qui éclaire aussi a été
repris comme étant la deuxième halte est
il donc tout doit être construit autour
de se gérer de ces idées là et puis en
même temps c'est une équipe c'est une
équipe de france qu'on entend construire
on parle forcément des 2 2 qui soudain
les au second tour on a besoin aussi de
tout le monde de tous les études à la
fois de delambre kim également de dédé
et berthe seul on a besoin d'avoir une
équipe pour montrer qu'à un moment donné
et bien c'est une volonté collective de
trouver une solution alternative pour la
france et à partir de là dès lors qu'on
est sur une capacité de réellement dire
ce qu'on va faire et donner de la
crédibilité au sucre éviter à la fois
sur la ligne politique s'il crie vite
également trait à l'expérience des uns
des autres et chante là on a vraiment
les clés de réussite clairement quels
sont les thèmes qui ont fâché le plus on
a parlé beaucoup d'immigration
d'islamisme on va parler d'économie
aussi mais qu'elles sont au sein des
proches d'eric ciotti les plus grandes
craintes si j'ose dire quelles sont les
propositions sur lesquelles vous ne
dérangerait pas du côté surtout si vous
en avez évidemment possibilités
je crois d'abord si on veut rassembler
aucun des candidats pas plus valérie
pécresse que eric ciotti ne peut dire ça
sera mon programme tout mon programme
rien que mon programme et je prends rien
d autre donc il faut bien trouver à un
moment donné l'enjeu qu'il faut trouver
la crête il faut trouver la ligne rouge
je crois que sur les sujets régaliens
qui touche qui touche à l'immigration
qui touche à l'identité nationale qui
touche à la sécurité
je pense que tous les deux
[Musique]
ont trouvé un terrain d'entente alors
évidemment il ya quelques totem ya
quelques totem comme par exemple la
question du droit du sol ou du droit du
sang on va pas forcément demandé à
valérie pécresse de reprendre à son
compte cette proposition mais quand on
parle de des propositions de valérie
pécresse est pas forcément un mois de
deûle et de l'est comment dire de les
revendiquer puisque moi je soutenais
eric ciotti mais aujourd'hui je soutient
valérie pécresse donc je ne vais pas
commencer à dire c'est ça ou rien et je
pense pas qu eric ciotti dit c'est ça ou
rien je pense qu'eric ciotti a raison
dans l'intérêt de valérie pécresse dans
l'intérêt de notre famille politique de
vouloir bien crantée un certain nombre
de propositions à minima sur les sujets
que je vient d'élaborer mais mais mais
il ya autre chose il ya l'économie ou
désir
de regarder les différences passées en
tout cas sur les grandes questions qui
touchent à l'immigration on a bien vu
pendant cette campagne j'en termine
gentilly pour dire que les deux projets
les deux projets d'ailleurs c'est à
noter sur les cinq candidats les deux
projets qui étaient le plus à droite
c'était justement les deux projets
d'eric ciotti elle valérie pécresse et
ils sont arrivés en tête ça veut dire
quelque chose il faut bien penser à cela
regardez ouais c'est ces convergences et
des divergences sur l'immigration fin de
l'aide médicale d'état sauf urgence
supprimer les aides sociales aux
sans-papiers prestations sociales 1
conditionnée à une durée de résidence
sur le territoire c'est ce qu'ont en
commun les deux candidats divergences
sur l'immigration des quotas par métier
par pays phares du droit du sol
automatique et priorités nationales pour
les emplois restaurer le droit du sang
supprimant le droit du sol philippe
bouyer c'est ce sont des propositions
sacchi son attention
elle a évoqué justement le débat sans
droit du sol voilà on voit bien qu on va
devoir faire agir est une union un
trader déjà les bases communes et puis
ensuite on va discuter par point pour
avoir d'autres positionnement voilà mais
aujourd'hui le débat est sur la table
mais surtout ce que le plus important
c'est ce qui nous rassemble que plus
fondamental les plus importants donc ça
veut dire qu'à partir de là eh bien on
doit trouve sur un projet reprenant et
bien des positionnements des uns des
autres pour trouver la meilleure
synthèse voilà donc un partenaire ou
alors on parle je peux pas vous évoquez
la veut la discussion dans tous les cas
le sujet sur la table et c'était parti
des démarches c'est vrai pour les
thématiques évoquées c'est vraiment
devenu de l'économie on a quand même
beaucoup de sujets en matière de
réformes parlons de l'état les chiffres
varient mais la volonté commune de
réformer l'état est identique chez les
deux candidats on va dire qu'aujourd'hui
les points communs sont largement plus
important que le reste alexis blanc
c'est vrai ça en tant qu'observateur les
points communs sont plus importants que
les divergences entre les candidats
c'est aussi votre votre analyse oui on a
vu d'ailleurs durant tous les débats
pour le prendre la tête et avoir la
candidature à l'issue de ce congrès les
il y avait une volonté de chercher les
convergences plutôt que les divergences
de montrer l'union du camp républicain
compte tenu de ce qu'on a en face à où
la gauche est totalement émietté donc là
il ya une stratégie globale du parti qui
est celle de l'unité de montrer qu hier
une équipe qui est prête à gouverner qui
est prêt à s'entendre maintenant
évidemment les tractations les
divergences et elles vont pas être
montrée en public au grand jour il y
aura sans doute beaucoup de travail un
des clips pour arriver à faire un
programme commun ça s'appelle la
synthèse ça se fait dans les grands
partis et ça va être fait dans les
semaines qui viennent dans les mois qui
viennent pour présenter à moi un
programme cohérent avec bien sûr la
prise en compte de cette droitisation à
la fois de l'électorat et aussi du
programme d'aidé républicain et puis
peut-être le retour du court mais lestée
de laurent wauquiez d'une certaine façon
puisque lui et est parti par la petite
porte lorsqu'il était président et là on
voit que des années après ces années et
d'idées ont gagné et qu'on arrive à
débattre sur cette base programmatique
donc c'est quand même un pas important
vers une sorte de républicains 2.0 alors
droitisation évidemment sur ces
questions régaliennes immigration
question aussi de l'identité des
islamistes mais aussi vous avez commencé
en parlais tout à l'heure ce joyandet le
projet économiquement ça m'a un petit
peu frappés parce que c'est vrai qu'on
emprunte peut-être un petit peu moins
enfin il y ait des différences majeures
bon suppression des d'un certain nombre
de fonctionnaires côté pécresse mais
enfin surtout cet impôt sur le revenu à
15% pour eric ciotti alors que valérie
pécresse a elle veut donner un coup de
pouce à des salaires qui vont jusqu'à
3500 euros parce qu'elle souhaitait
augmenter de 10% en baissant les charges
sociales pas du tout la même ligne sur
l' on est déjà là on est déjà dans
l'application des mesures donc ça
j'allais dire que ça change beaucoup de
choses pour beaucoup de français
j'allais dire justement une chose c'est
que pour les français le plus important
on a parlé beaucoup des questions
identitaires mais pour les français la
question c'est quand même comment
j'améliore mes conditions de vie
aujourd'hui on a des français qui
travaillent et bien qu'il travaille qui
ne s'en sortent plus avec des charges
sociales qui sont absolument écrasante
et la question du financement du travail
est de 2,2 le travailler plus pour
travailler plus travailler plus pour
gagner plus pardon c'est toujours vrai
et c'est toujours ce que les français
attendent on voit bien que les deux
candidats sur ces questions là sont
quand même plus où tous d'accord parce
que la grande question qui concerne les
finances publiques et les finances
sociales ou qu au sens large si si on ne
réduit pas les charges de l'état
personne ne pourra améliorer la
situation des français sur ce sujet
fondamental
eric ciotti valérie pécresse qui baisse
les charges de l'état pour redonner cet
argent en rémunération du travail c'est
quand même essentiel est là dessus ils
sont d'accord alors après la flat tax ou
faire autrement évidemment ce sont des
ce sont des choses qui qui sont
différentes mais je pense que là encore
il y aura quelque chose à trouver pour
baisser massivement les impôts financent
et cela par la réduction de la dépense
publique pour redonner en rémunération
du travail des français je crois que
là-dessus c'est quand même l'essentiel
ils sont d'accord oui je dirais pas du
tout oui il ya une logique de baisse des
impôts ça c'était pas les trois
principaux évoqués c'est le train de vie
de l'état c'est la baisse des impôts on
discutera à quel niveau quelles sont les
priorités et puis un moment donné
comment on redonne notamment à ce que
n'ont plus besoin à vos enfants si
aujourd'hui des travailleurs pauvres
c'est pato nattes des gens qui se
mobilisent qui travaillent il faut
trouver des solutions là il ya des
pistes qui sont sur la table on va les
affiner mais le principe général qui a
été décrit par alain est exactement le
principe qui est porté par les candidats
puisse rapporter d'autres projets
politiques alexis pour le mot de la fin
pour vous justement sur cette question
économique ce pouvoir d'achat très
attendu indice que c'est la
préoccupation principale aujourd'hui des
des français dans cette campagne
oui clairement pour le rachat qui s'est
invité à la dernière minute dans cette
campagne est menée lé mac on ne comptait
pas du tout faire campagne sur ce thème
et son bilan est bien maigre en matière
de pouvoir d'achat donc là il va falloir
proposer et il ya bien sûr rendre
l'emploi attractifs crée davantage
d'emplois la baisse des impôts c'est un
peu près dans tous les programmes pour
pâques mais les français sont attachés
aussi à leur modèle social donc il faut
ménager la chèvre est toujours le voir
avec la crise de l'hôpital il faut faire
extrêmement attention peut-être qu'il y
a des services publics prioritaires à
mettre en avant et d'autres à repenser
et puis il ya bien sûr une nouvelle
imposition du 21e siècle a cherché avec
gabegie dans les dépenses publiques ce
n'est pas nouveau c'est la france a un
taux d'imposition énorme et et pourtant
dans l'impression que les services
publics ne sont pas à la auteur donc il
ya un vrai problème ce problème là c'est
peut-être plus d'un quinquennat qu'il
faudrait pour s'y atteler mais
clairement il va falloir régler ce
problème du pouvoir d'achat compliqué
parce que par exemple l'énergie ça ne
peut pas se régler rapidement si on veut
construire de nouvelles centrales avoir
de l'éolien un mix énergétique qui fait
qu'on va pouvoir baisser le prix et
plusieurs années là encore
d'investissement et est tout tout est un
peu pareil sur tous les dossiers donc il
va falloir trouver une solution et
elle est pas forcément évident donc
c'est sûr merci ça sera le mot de la fin
en tout cas merci alexis poulain merci à
vous deux philippe houllier alain
joyandet d'avoir été avec tous deux
placés sur le plateau d'ayrté france
merci à vous